[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous je m'appelle
Raphaël mon surnom c'est Rafiki ça veut
dire l'ami je suis l'ami de tout le
monde quand je rencontre des gens je me
sens tout de suite avec une affinité
avec eux et c'est une particularité que
j'ai
quand j'avais 14 ans j'étais amoureux
d'une fille que j'aimais beaucoup et je
passais beaucoup de temps au téléphone
avec elle on avait un petit jeu on se
racontait des histoires le soir et
j'inventais une histoire qui est devenue
aujourd'hui ma philosophie de vie je
vais vous le raconter donc c'est
histoire d'une mouche qui arrive dans le
quartier des mouches elle arrive
[Musique]
hé mon chat merde vas-y viens jouer avec
nous elle a dit arrêtez de m'appeler
mouche la merde moi je suis pas une
mouche à merde mais oui parce que j'aime
bien
il joue ensemble ils jouent jusqu'à la
tombée de la nuit et vous savez les
mouches sont attirés par la lumière et
la mouche à merde a dit vous allez voir
que moi je suis pas une mouche à merde
je voulais juste que la lumière de
l'arrêt de bus là-bas tout en haut et
sera moins la première on fait une
course
elle commence à faire le top départ 3
1 d'accord
[Musique]
tu es tombé dans ma toile c'est moi
l'araignée maintenant je vais te manger
il peut commencer
arrête arrête moi j'ai une mouche de
compétition je suis une super mouche
tu es une super mouche comme Spider-Man
et dit ouais comme Spider-Man moi je
suis Spider-Man mouche
qu'est-ce que tu sais faire comme super
pouvoir elle dit moi je suis une mouche
de compétition je peux voler je veux
rien
là-bas l'immeuble la dernière lumière
tout en haut de l'immeuble est-ce que tu
arrives à voler jusque là
où je veux
d'accord je le vois
il faut aller voir
elle arrive jusque où tout en haut de
l'immeuble aucune mouche n'a jamais été
tout en haut de cet immeuble et là la
mouche
puisque j'ai fait moi je suis une mouche
de compétition juste Spider-Man
et là un oiseau énorme
je suis l'aigle
mouche je t'ai vu voler jusqu'ici mais
tu ne peux pas voler plus haut personne
ne peut voler où il veut ah oui moi j'ai
une manche de compétition je vole aux
cheveux l'aigle il dit non et là il
commence à apprendre la mouche un peu
non c'est bras pour la cacher quelque
chose la mouche elle voit à travers les
plumes de l'aigle elle voit une lumière
énorme elle a jamais vu ça
moi je voulais juste que là-bas avec non
personne ne peut voler jusqu'au soleil
si moi je vais y aller
voilà et vous savez le soleil se lève à
l'ouest et se couche à l'est donc la
mouche elle vole à l'ouest elle suit
soleil
et ça faisait tous les jours elle
recommence mais il arrive jamais jamais
elle recommence je commence à être
fatigué elle commence à être fatigué
elle tombe de fatigue
et là elle voit quoi
il est devenu un grand entrepreneur avec
son œil il voit tout il a ouvert une
entreprise de de caméra et quand tu es
tombé quoi tu es tombé et voilà régné
l'araignée c'est devenu une artiste une
artiste incroyable même les humains ils
viennent prendre c'est toi la photo et
quand tu es tombé là elle tombe au
quartier des mouches et là c'est des
mouches elle voit
tous ses amis
ils ont tous une maison tous une famille
ils ont l'air d'être heureux alors que
elle toute sa vie tout ce qu'elle a fait
c'est que voler tellement fatiguée
et puis elle meurt
et
c'est la fin
mais non non non
c'est une mouche de compétition c'est
une super mouche et Spider-Man et donc
quand elle meurt quand elle meurt
écoutait bien quand elle meurt et ben
son
âme son âme son vol jusqu'au soleil
mesdames messieurs n'abandonnez jamais
vos rêves
et ça merci
et ça pour moi c'est devenu vraiment une
philosophie de vie je me suis dit j'ai
envie d'être comme cette mouche d'avoir
ce plaisir là à réaliser objectif avec
toujours heureux enthousiaste à vraiment
aimer ce qu'on fait même si elle a rien
créé à la peur une entreprise elle est
pas devenue une grande artiste au moins
elle a aimé ce qu'elle faisait jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie il me dit mais comment
est-ce que peut approcher à ça j'ai
réfléchi et pas très loin pas très
poussé vous allez voir c'est très simple
et j'ai mis trois étapes trois simples
étapes à ajouter
à son rythme de vie je lis le titre
parce que je viens d'apprendre de
maintenant j'ai oublié que j'avais mis
ça ajouter à son rythme de vie
et donc l'État sont vraiment très simple
la première étape c'est
fait ce que vous aimez oui c'est un
piste on le sait tous ce que je vais
vous dire vous savez mais c'est bien de
se le remémorer de leur avoir en tête
faites ce que vous aimez
quand vous allez dans un magasin vous
allez dans l'artisan boulanger
vous voyez des fois la phrase fait avec
amour
c'est pas qu'un argument de vente c'est
un sentiment quand même un peu plus
profond
vous prenez deux artisans un artisan qui
fait avec un amour il travaille il aime
ce qu'il fait un autre artisan c'est
juste son travail il va travailler pour
travailler oui la question que je vais
vous poser
lequel des deux a le potentiel d'aller
plus loin
c'est celui qui fait avec amour pourquoi
parce que lui certes c'est un travail
mais ce qu'il fait c'est une passion il
l'aime
il apprécie tant qu'il y passe il compte
pas le temps passer dedans à berenstein
a dit un jour
si vous posez votre main pendant une
minute sur un poil long chaud
ça va paraître une heure mais si vous
vous asseyez sur un banc une heure à
côté d'une jolie fille ça paraîtra une
minute c'est vraiment Bergen qu'il a dit
c'est la théorie de la relativité c'est
ça la relativité
et c'est la même chose quand on aime un
travail c'est la même chose on ne compte
pas le temps qu'on y passe et on est
capable d'en faire plus d'aller plus
loin de dépasser les limites comme la
mouche la mouche elle a adorée voler ce
qu'elle a fait toute sa vie c'est voler
elle a voulu voler voler voler jusqu'à
voler là aucune mouche n'a jamais été
elle a dépassé les limites donc l'eau
faire ce que vous aimez peut vous
permettre de dépasser les limites
existantes j'ai marché de Liège jusque
Rome à pied dans un nettoyage et je
rencontrais un architecte
et il m'a appris que quand on aimait les
choses et bien la réalisation de nos
objectifs était beaucoup plus belle
il m'a dit j'ai construit ma maison et
je voulais finir par ma chambre
et le temps que ma chambre n'était pas
finie je ne dormirai pas dedans j'ai dit
ok il m'a dit ma maison maintenant il
est fini et le premier soir je dormais
dans ma chambre mais au détail près elle
a fini sa chambre avec le miroir bien
posé les draps accordés au rideau
fini au détail près j'ai dormi dedans
mais avant j'ai pleuré j'ai pleuré toute
la soirée mais pourquoi est-ce que tu as
pleuré tu as fini ta maison tu dois être
content maintenant j'étais triste
pourquoi tu étais triste il m'a dit bah
parce que j'ai fini mon travail
maintenant j'ai aimé travailler ma
maison qu'est-ce que je vais faire c'est
fini ça l'a rendu triste d'avoir fini
son travail vous imaginez qu'il est
triste alors finissent son travail à
part lui je vous jure je comprenais pas
je me suis dit mais qu'est-ce qui
raconte lui et puis après quand j'ai
fini de marcher jusqu'à Rome arriver au
panneau à la fin j'ai ressenti le même
sentiment et j'ai réussi à
l'immortaliser
j'avais dit c'est posé cette maison on
peut laisser tout ce que vous voulez
hier je reviens après ça j'ai marché
[Musique]
2 restez-vous même soyez authentique je
me suis souvent posé la question mais à
quoi ça sert adresser soi-même on peut
on peut mettre des masques avec
quelqu'un différent et tout ça sert à
quoi ça sert et j'ai quand même ça par
contre assez longuement réfléchi et ce
qui m'a mis une puce à l'oreille c'est
ce personnage Forest Gump j'ai choisi
parce que aussi aussi un mec simple
voilà tout le monde peut être comme lui
tout le monde a ses compétences dans le
film il est montré comme un Nido
et pourtant il devient le plus grand
entrepreneur du film devient
godzillionaire c'est ce qu'ils disent il
est godzillionaire milliardaire et tout
ça en restant authentique en restant
lui-même on va aller un peu plus loin en
prenant quelqu'un de beaucoup plus
intelligent c'est Stromae
Stromae c'est un artiste qui je pense on
peut tous déclarer authentique pourquoi
mais bien parce que quand il partage sa
musique et partager ce qu'il le touche
il partage sa dépression il partage
l'absence de son père
il partage le cancer des personnes qui
étaient proches de Lui partage des
choses qui va appartiennent ce sont une
partie de lui en plus de ça on voit
qu'il aime ce qu'il fait parce que il
innove il va plus loin il dépasse ses
limites on va voir un de ses concerts il
est bien habillé avec des vêtements
qu'on a jamais vu il fait il fait
habiller des robots qui dansent des
chorégraphies j'ai jamais vu ça moi des
robots qui sont habillés qui dansent des
chorégraphies voilà il aime ce qui fait
dépasser limite et à votre avis
Stromae s'il n'était pas resté lui-même
authentique
est-ce qu'il aurait eu autant de succès
je ne pense pas et surtout à retenir
c'est là que la clé est-ce qu'il aurait
autant d'opportunités dans la musique si
tu n'étais pas authentique et pas
lui-même l'opportunité quelle
opportunité l'opportunité de nous
toucher l'opportunité toucher son
entourage les personnes qui l'ont
produite et qui l'ont amené à là où il
est revenons maintenant à à Forrest Gump
Forrest Gump
toutes les opportunités qui ont été
données ont été des opportunités qui
sont faites pour lui un idiot dans ce
film il joue au ping-pong et c'est le
film qu'il dit qu'on vous écoutez bien
il dit jouer au ping-pong ça va porter
de n'importe quel idiot il devient
champion du monde de ping-pong
il parcourir sans réfléchir comme ça et
il devient une plus grande star
américaine il fonde une entreprise de
crevettes alors que il y a des bateaux
bien me perfectionner que le sien est
bien meilleur que le sien une
concurrence énorme et il arrive quand
même à devenir à devenir milliardaire
grâce à ce bateau il y a qu'un idiot qui
peut entrer avec un bateau si mauvais
dans une si grande concurrence mais il a
quand même réussi et les opportunités
qui sont venues vers lui sont venus
pourquoi parce qu'il est resté lui-même
authentique quand vous restez vous-même
les opportunités qui vont arriver vers
vous sont faites pour vous des
opportunités qui sont faites où vous
pouvez briller dedans
3 ne jamais rester sur place c'est la
chose que vous allez le plus regretter
au monde ne jamais rester sur place
toujours essayer de faire quelque chose
quand on interroge des vieilles
personnes ils disent toujours à j'aurais
dû profiter quand j'étais jeune ah j'ai
pas regretté de faire ça etc etc faut
toujours essayer d'être en mouvement la
mouche vous l'avez vu elle elle a pas
hésité par tes volets
si même pas même collègue lui dit non
c'est pas possible elle a été et ça
qu'on veut Forester tout le temps en
mouvement après vous allez me dire
maintenant moi je sais pas aller vers où
ça arrive souvent je sais pas aller vers
ou pas faire le petit 1 et le petit 2
vers les choses que vous aimez et les
choses qui vous permettent de rester
vous-même et là imaginons que vous avez
un travail ça c'est le chemin vous avez
un travail des études que vous aimez pas
trop ça fait une marche par là OK et
puis un moment vous pensez à ce que je
vous ai dit voilà le petit le petit 2
vous faites un petit pas un tout petit
pas je mens pas de faire un saut vous
faire un bon déliminer toute façon de
stabilité non un petit pas vers les
choses que vous aimez commentez vous
changez déjà de direction vous voyez si
vous cherchez un marché vers travail
études encore un petit peu encore un
petit peu encore un petit peu encore un
petit peu un petit peu là je vous
promets qu'un jour et j'en suis certain
à force de faire ce pas
et bien les opportunités viendront vers
vous vous marchez que dans cette
direction cette direction là c'est
laquelle la direction de la mouche
conclusion faites ce que vous aimez vous
permet de dépasser les limites
existantes
2 restez-vous même soyez authentique
saisie va vous permettre de saisir des
opportunités qui vous ressemble 3 ne
jamais rester immobile va vous permettre
d'éviter de culpabiliser plus tard le
temps Nathan pas le temps
et vous mettez cette 3 étapes de votre
rythme de vie tu sais c'est pas c'est
pas une grosse étape un petit pas comme
ça
je répète une dernière fois ah en fait
ce que vous aimez de rester vous-même ne
jamais rester immobile mesdames
messieurs n'abandonnez jamais de
mauvaises merci
[Applaudissements]